okay so we're comparing a circles area
as compared to its radius okay now the
question says write the relationship
between the variables using K as the
constant of variation so that's why you
can see why I infused K can't community
number you like but the key is that it's
constant whereas Y and X are variable
they can change okay so I think they're
calling this guy a for area and because
the area of a circle
it varies directly not with the radius
but with the square of the radius this
is the way I would write this okay now
this is a formula we're very familiar
with we know what K is it has its own
special name what is it it's fine so pi
I'm gonna label it here I'd love you to
do it as well pi is the constant of
variation or the constant of
proportionality different words same
idea
okay so this statement here fits into
this guy here right you could say the
area is proportional to the square of
the radius now I want us to do something
interesting in here underneath could you
please draw a set of axes I need some
more space because we're dealing with
measurements an area and also a length
what I'd like us to do is only to draw
the top right-hand side of a Cartesian
plan because we only need the positive
parts for radius and the positive parts
for area okay so join yourself up
something like this I have a vertical
axis and a horizontal axis which one
would you like to make the radius which
one do you think makes sense the
horizontal axis so I will point out its
some we usually call this guy the x-axis
but it's not the x-axis it's the radius
the R axis in this case so I'll just
label it R that makes the other guy a I
agree that that's a natural choice
because usually we would think of area
depending on radius so it's dependent
now what I'd like you to do is with the
help of your friends next to you just
get a few values maybe we could go up to
say oh maybe something like say R equals
4 so if I have 0 over here go 1 2 3 4
find out what you're gonna get as the
biggest value so you can settle on an
appropriate scale and then I'd like you
to plot the points then we can join them
up and get a shape can you do that for
me
get some values we know what the
constant is so it's PI R squared go
ahead and try some things and see what
you get I do
where is your Saviour you need it
the the wiggly thing actually I don't
know its name
I think of it as that I call it the
proportionality symbol but I do know
that all kinds of things have proper
names like I keep doing this this is not
the end symbol this is actually called
the air force and we call this a hash
tag but it's actually called the
octothorpe they all have different names
yeah and that's yeah well anyway so I
don't know what then there if you look
it up proportionality symbol something
like that look it up yeah see if you
[Music]
even things like this you know how we
call this the square root symbol it's
actually called the the radix symbol
well radical actually means root that's
actually the it's the and it's the same
thing that radius means anyway it's the
adjective of root in Latin I think so
yeah yes okay
has someone decided on what the highest
value will be just so I can start to
draw a scale fifty point two six five so
therefore maybe I'll put it 60 how about
that
okay now some of these are easy to do
for example when R equals 0 when R
equals 0 I know what the area will be
when R 0 what's the area it's just 0 so
I can put a point there there's my first
point when R equals 1 it's just as easy
to calculate R squared is 1 so 1 squared
rather so it'll just be PI which is like
3.14 ok so on my scale here I've got 15
here so I'm gonna be have to be quite
low I'm gonna put it as something like
that what you get for 2 when R is 2 what
is the area twelve point five seven
Thank You Vera I'm still below my 15
marker when R equals three anyone got 28
point two seven okay so I'm somewhere
about there and my last one
Elliot you said that was 50 ish right 50
okay thank you very much
28 okay so you can see here the shape
that we're tracing out predictably is
the shape of a it's a parabola now
here's the funny thing
we're used to seeing thinkyou problems
when there are X Squared's around right
but this is just a different labeling of
an x squared I'm just using a different
letter I can call it whatever squared I
like they could call it s squared or T
squared or holy squared that's a scary
idea so I can give this label anything I
want so I just look at you know that so
this is a parabola just like anything
else even though it's an R not an X can
you join them up for me is it now
exponential growth and this kind of
growth do look very similar on a small
scale but exponential growth will always
outrun growth like this so and that's
why we call it exponential now here's
where it gets really weird and
interesting okay this is a graph and
this is worth actually naming this this
is a graph of a the area
and he's a weird use of the word but
they use the word against this is a
graph of area against radius okay what
they mean is the area is one axis and
the radius is the other okay